[Applaus]
[Musik]
sorry kalifornien ein wunderschönes land
das nach einer insel aus der
griechischen mythologie benannt ist und
dessen spitzname golden state lautet ein
füllhorn aus dem sich die meisten
staaten dieser erde ernähren könnten es
ist weltberühmt für seine majestätischen
strände und mammutbäume die so alt sind
wie jesus christus
all diese wunde kannst du erleben wenn
du dich nur einen tag lang auf
entdeckungstour begibt in dieses land
der patient fuß kalifornien ist aber
nicht nur verdammt schön sondern auch
verdammt reich im jahr 2017 hatte
kalifornien mit einer bevölkerung von
knapp 40 millionen einwohnern ein
bruttoinlandsprodukt von fast drei
billionen dollar das sind ein paar
hundert millionen dollar mehr als das
bruttoinlandsprodukt von indien einem
land mit mehr als 1,3 milliarden
einwohnern also mehr als 32 mal so
vielen menschen das reale pro kopf
bruttoinlandsprodukt kaliforniens
beträgt fast 69.000 dollar denen das
indische weniger als 2.000 dollar
betrieb
[Musik]
dieser riesige reichtum macht
kalifornien zu einem der reichsten orte
der welt es ist die sechst größte
volkswirtschaft der erde etwas so groß
die die französische obwohl es über 26
millionen weniger menschen verfügt eine
freiheitliche gesellschaft in der einige
der reichsten menschen der
menschheitsgeschichte leben errichtet in
einer landschaft die den garten eden
leicht was für ein himmlischer ort auf
erden am liebsten würde ich mir jetzt
ein paar blumen ins haar stecken okay
vielleicht ist es einigen von euch
aufgefallen dass dies alles eigentlich
viel zu gut klingt um wahr zu sein
falls nicht dann werdet ihr eventuell
überrascht sein dass alle paar jahre
nachrichten wie die folgenden aus diesem
land der träume kommen
[Musik]
kalifornien hat wieder ein
haushaltsdefizit sagt gouverneur jerry
brown l s 2017 weniger als vier jahre
nachdem er den kalifornischen haushalt
für die absehbare zukunft ausgeglichen
erklärt hatte sagte gouverneur jerry
brown am dienstag dass der start bis zum
nächsten sommer ein defizit von 1,6
milliarden dollar verzeichnen wird
[Musik]
das kalifornische stalking ist die
größte stadt der usa die sich für
zahlungsunfähig erklären musste cbs 2012
diese nachrichten sind nun schon ein
paar jahre alt und mittlerweile weiß der
kalifornische staatshaushalt einen recht
gesunden überschuss aus das ist jetzt
aber nicht der knackpunkt denn selbst
wenn die staatsfinanzen gerade jetzt
einigermaßen tragbar sind kann man ist
darauf nehmen dass dies nicht lange so
bleiben wird da finanzkrisen in
kalifornien eine immer wiederkehrend
angelegenheit sind und auch ganz ohne
eine aktuelle krise der staatlichen
finanzen ist auf den straßen san
franciscos und ganz kaliforniens
momentan die kacke ganz wortwörtlich am
dampfen was wir damit konkret meinen in
diesem video werdet ihr alles erfahren
zuvor aber müssen wir uns ein paar
grundsätzliche fragen stellen wie kann
es sein dass ein staat mit derart hohen
steuersätzen wo zudem einige der
reichsten menschen der welt
so häufig in zahlungsschwierigkeiten
gerät ist für dieses problem irgendeine
lösung in aussicht wie wirkt sich dies
auf den alltag der california aus heute
werden wir euch antworten auf all diese
fragen geben lasst uns dazu zunächst
einen blick in die geschichte werden
kaliforniens finanzielle menge nur also
fangen wir an wenn sie uns mit einem so
großen problem befassen wollen versuchen
wir es mal mit den steuereinnahmen und
den staatsausgaben kalifornien gibt eine
menge geld aus und häufig mehr als es
notwendig wäre aber über welche summen
reden wir hier sehr große der
staatshaushalt 2009 10 20 betrug satte
200 9 milliarden dollar
was größer ist als das gesamte bip
griechenlands wobei man bedenken muss
dass griechenland eine eigenständige
nation ist während kalifornien nur ein
bundesstaat ist und die usa als nation
auch noch mal über einen dicken
bundeshaushalt
[Musik]
aber das ist noch nicht alles solche
summen sind nämlich selbst für
kalifornische verhältnisse sehr hoch
denn sie hören einfach nicht auf immer
mehr geld auszugeben im vergleich der
haushalt 2008 09 war mit 124 milliarden
dollar ebenfalls groß aber immer noch 50
milliarden dollar billiger aber schon
damals war eigentlich zu groß denn wenn
man ins jahr 1990 zurück geht betrug der
inflationsbereinigte haushalte noch 100
eine milliarde dollar
so ist es die stars ausgaben des staates
kalifornien haben sich binnen 30 jahren
inflationsbereinigt mehr als verdoppelt
und wohin verschwindet dieses ganze geld
nun es gibt eine menge löcher in
kalifornien der staat unternahm zum
beispiel den versuch ein 80 milliarden
dollar teures hochgeschwindigkeits
eisenbahnnetz von l
durch das central valley bauen zu lassen
obwohl der preis für dieses vorhaben
ständig steigt
[Musik]
ein langfristiges beispiel sind die
health and human services also
eigentlich gesundheits und
sozialausgaben diese betrugen 2008 10
und 19 fast 5 milliarden dollar das
waren 3,8 milliarden dollar
gesundheitsversorgung von kindern und
knapp 200 millionen an sozialleistungen
für ältere menschen zum vergleich die
ausgaben des zweitgrößten bundesstaat
der usa texas für diese art von
sozialleistungen betragen exakt 0 dollar
dafür sind die steuersätze in texas
wesentlich niedriger als in kalifornien
und viele kalifornien würden natürlich
lieber den texanische steuersatz zahlen
als ihren eigenen aber sind die pflege
kranker kinder und die fürsorge für
ältere menschen nicht genau jene dinge
für die wir eigentlich steuern brauchen
was für ein problem haben wir also damit
nun ehrlich gesagt die simple tatsache
dass der kalifornische staat ist einfach
nicht schafft das wachstum der ausgaben
mit denen der einnahmen irgendwie
einklang zu bringen
[Musik]
und nehmen wir an du bist california und
du arbeitest zum beispiel gleich als
programmierer bei google oder facebook
oder als manager bei monsanto oder als
ingenieur in einer ölraffinerie sonne
theron oder eben als handlanger
irgendeines anderen bösen konzerts
inwieweit braucht es dich denn dann
überhaupt zu interessieren dass die
regierung ein paar milliarden dollar
schulden macht wahrscheinlich nicht
wissen was viel und eigentlich wäre es
auch überraschend wenn bürger über die
details des staatshaushalts bescheid
wussten und besteht nicht der
unterschied zwischen kalifornien und
ländern wie griechenland oder
argentinien
darin dass alle vorher mit globalen
konzernen weltklasse universitäten einer
blühenden landwirtschaft hollywood sowie
der höchsten konzentration an venture
capital überhaupt aufwarten kann mit
anderen worten seine wirtschaft ist
extrem diversifiziert das alles bedeutet
dass kalifornien gelegentliche defizite
aushalten kann weil es ja einfach so gut
ist warum zum teufel ist dann also immer
wieder die rede von irgendwelchen
finanzprobleme sind es alles einfach nur
neider spalte und miesepeter die ewig an
kalifornien und der kalifornischen
politikers
nun fangen wir bei den steuern an es gab
eine zeit zu der die kalifornische
regierung anklingen geld wie verrückt
auszugeben was immer für dinge wie
sozialhilfe renten und gefängnisse in
denen der platz immer zu schnell zu
knapp wird sie schaffte es dabei das
geld für ihre ausgaben orgien immer
irgendwo aufzutreiben aber wo kam dieses
ganze geld her nun es wurde er leider
nicht von kobolden geschenkt also
mussten in kalifornien die sowieso schon
recht hohen steuersätze kräftig erhöht
werden
[Musik]
nun muss man verstehen dass man in den
usa zunächst einkommenssteuer an denen
bot zahlen muss diese ist ähnlich wie in
deutschland progressiv gestaffelt und
beträgt je nach einkommenshöhe 10 bis 40
prozent während in deutschland damit
jedoch die steuerschuld erfüllt ist
können in den usa einzelne bundesstaaten
noch mal ihre eigenen einkommen steuern
erheben und kalifornien hat hier den
höchsten maximalen einkommenssteuersatz
aller staaten von über 13 prozent zum
vergleich der staat mit dem zweit
höchsten steuersatz in den usa ist mit
elf prozent außerdem heben die beiden
nächsten bevölkerungsreichsten staaten
texas und leute und fünf weitere
bundesstaaten überhaupt keine
einkommenssteuer mit der
einkommensbesteuerung hört dies aber
noch nicht auf dazu kommen nämlich pro
grundsteuern hohe steuersätze auf
kapitalgewinne und eine hohe
körperschaftsteuer wenigstens hat
kalifornien keinen sehr hohen
mehrwertsteuersatz vor allem für
europäische verhältnisse aber dieser ist
immer noch der 10 höchste der usa okay
jetzt wo er lässt wo die 200 milliarden
dollar her kommen werdet ihr wohl immer
noch sagen wenn die größten megakonzern
der welt hohe steuern von ihren
gigantischen gewinnen zahlen müssen wie
so kämpft der staat derart mit seinen
finanzen das problem besteht darin dass
dank der steuerprogression eben ein
großteil der steuereinnahmen
kaliforniens von den reichen kommt die
wohlhabendsten 3% zahlen dabei 60
prozent der einkommenssteuer
dies bringt jedoch ein großes problem
ist eine hohe fähigkeit von eben diesen
mega einkommen der staat ist ihnen auf
gedeih und verderb ausgeliefert wenn es
den superreichen den mega kurs herren
und den risikokapitalgebern also
wirtschaftlich gut geht scheffelt auch
der kalifornische staat steuergelder wie
verrückt wenn es dann aber mal schlecht
läuft wenn die aktienkurse crashen
riskante investitionen nicht aufgehen
und die renditen der unternehmen nicht
mehr in den himmel wachsen stürzte die
steuereinnahmen schneller ab als eine
boeing 737 max 8 die meisten anderen
volkswirtschaften mit hohen steuern
weisen diese charakteristik instabilität
nicht im gleichen maße auf die
kalifornien schweden zum beispiel dass
sich auch durch außerordentlich hohe
steuersätze auszeichnet ist weniger
anfällig für einkommens volatilität
warum weil sein steuersysteme
diversifizierter ist zum beispiel hat
schweden eine mehrwertsteuer von 25
prozent also dreimal höher als in
kalifornien eine solchen steuerpolitik
gilt als aggressiv weil sowohl reiche
als auch weniger reiche auf ähnliche
weise zur kasse gebeten werden aber sie
hat einen entscheidenden vorteil
konsumausgaben schwanken nicht so stark
wie kapital und unternehmensgewinnen
denn egal wie gut oder schlecht ist an
der börse läuft man neigt dazu jede
woche lebensmittel einzukaufen den
urlaub zu fahren oder eben all das zeug
zu kaufen das man so fürs leben braucht
die umsatzsteuer ist also viel
zuverlässiger und während die
steuersätze in kalifornien sehr hoch
sind schwanken die steuereinnahmen jahr
für jahr sehr stark und lohnt sich
dieses kalifornische steuersystem hat
eine solche steuer progression in der
die reichen höhere abgaben zahlen auch
wenn diese schwanken mögen auch vorteile
welche ihre nachteile aufwiegen führt
wenigstens der aufgeblähte sozialstaat
der damit finanziert wird zu mehr
gerechtigkeit ist kalifornien eine
richtig progressive und wirtschaftlich
egalitäre gesellschaft herrscht dort die
von den meisten kalifornien so
herbeigesehnte soziale
gleichberechtigung nun
nicht wirklich das land der obdachlosen
in kalifornien herrscht nicht nur eine
grauenvolle einkommensungleichheit auf
der rangliste der bundesstaaten mit den
am meisten ungleichmäßig verteilten
einkommen belegt es platz drei gleich
hinter dem sozial problem staat
louisiana
sieben der 15 ungleichen städte amerikas
liegen im golden set und das ist noch
lange nicht das ende der fahnenstange
[Musik]
obdachlosigkeit in los angeles stieg in
sechs jahren um 75 prozent
dies ist der grund für die
jahrzehntelange krise los angeles times
2018 wenn die menschen in korea haben
ihre schicken kundus verlassen müssen
finden sie vor ihrer haustür zelte
verrottende essensreste und menschliche
ausscheidungen busse und züge sind de
facto zu schlafräumen geworden in denen
tausende von menschen verängstigt und
erniedrigt übernachten müssen
ja es sieht dort wirklich verdammt elend
aus so elend dass ihr gar keine
vorstellung davon haben und wenn ihr
nicht euren glauben die menschlichkeit
oder die gerechtigkeit verlieren möchte
kann ich nur raten nie nach sowas wie
california homeless men zu googeln das
ist man erst ihr werdet leider total
geschockt sein dass es so etwas in einem
entwickelten land überhaupt gehen dann
die kasse ungleichheit zwischen den
menschen ist aber nicht die alleinige
ursache für dieses elend die
stadtbevölkerung ist immer weiter
gewachsen und wirtschaftliche
besonderheiten die wir in einem anderen
video zum fall libyen wie aufzeigen
haben zu katastrophal hohen
lebenshaltungskosten geführt vor allem
die wohnkosten im märz 2009 10 lag der
landesweite medianwert für eine
zweizimmerwohnung bei 1.175 dollar
in los angeles bei 1772 dollar in san
diego bei 2.000 dollar und in san
francisco sagte 3165 dollar das ist aber
bei weitem noch nicht alles in
kalifornien sind die menschen noch
vielen anderen hohen belastungen
ausgesetzt
die überdurchschnittlich hohe
lebensmittelpreise und die höchsten
transportkosten im land und ist kommen
noch die extrem hohen steuersätze
obendrauf dieses system als extrem
überzogen zu bezeichnen wäre eine
grandiose untertreibung hinzu kommt dass
man mit aus lateinamerika importierten
billigarbeitskräften das lohnniveau zu
niedrig hält während die hightech
branche war sie die preise für alles in
die höhe treibt ungleicher geht es nicht
mehr
von 1980 bis 2015 stiegen die
inflationsbereinigten
für die unteren zehn prozent der
arbeitenden bevölkerung um 18 prozent
während die einkommen der ober- und fünf
um satte 122 stehen das bedeutet dass
jemand 1980 15.000 dollar im jahr
verdient jetzt 17.700 dollar verdient
während jemand der 100.000 dollar
verdiente jetzt 22.000 dollar ein
[Musik]
wenn man nun noch einige rand faktoren
einbezieht wie zum beispiel das schöne
wetter das obdachlose aus staaten mit
schlechteren wetterbedingungen anzieht
rede bauvorschriften die den bau neuer
wohnungen erschweren sowie eine
landesweite krise der psychischen
gesundheit dann erhält man ein
patentrezept um jene
parallelgesellschaften des elends
entstehen zu lassen die das kalifornien
von heute kennzeichnet ganze zeltstädte
voller verrückter fentanyl zuließ die in
den düsteren ecken der gleichen
metropolen dahin vegetieren in deren
luxus vierteln auch die eliten der
weltwirtschaft leben was also wird gegen
diese miesen zustände unternommen nun
eigentlich gar nichts das meine ich
jetzt wirklich vollkommen erst die
antwort der kommunalen regierungen in
denen die demokratische partei allesamt
überwältigende mehrheiten besitzt war
ohrenbetäubende stille viele
stadtverwaltungen wie zum beispiel die
von auckland bieten kurze zeit
unterkünfte für einige obdachlose an
welche zu bekommen so wahrscheinlich ist
wie ein sechser im lotto und nach sechs
monaten sind sie sowieso wieder auf der
straße im wesentlichen während die
obdachlosen einfach in die nächste stadt
abgeschoben wo durch zyklische wellen
von obdachlosen horden entstehen die
verzweifelt die ein flüchtlingszug von
region zu region ziehen die sie alle nur
so schnell wie möglich loswerden wollen
während im frostigen new york city etwa
95 der durchreisenden obdachlosen eine
unterkunft zur verfügung gestellt
bekommen sind dies in seattle noch knapp
60 prozent in san francisco weniger als
40 prozent und in san luis obispo nicht
mal 20 prozent
wohin fließen dann aber all die
steuergelder wenn der staat nicht mal
den ärmsten der armen hilft nun zb in
zwielichtige polizei aktionen wie jene
der stadt los angeles bei der im jahr
2016 selbst die kleine und ärmlichen
unterkünfte die eine private
wohltätigkeitsorganisation hat man
obdachlose gespendet hatte beschlagnahmt
und in einer müllverbrennungsanlage
entsorgt wurden dabei bräuchte
kalifornien dringend und drei millionen
notunterkünfte für obdachlose
um diese von der straße zu holen was ist
also das ergebnis dieses startphase
ganz vorne dreaming zum kalifornischen
albtraum kalifornien mag den man auch
der golden state sein aber es hat seinen
glanz verloren
volatile staatshaushalte instabilität
krasse ungleichheit und extrem hohe
lebenshaltungskosten belasten die
kalifornische gesellschaft in einer
weise die außenstehende so nicht
erwartet hätten
schaut euch mal folgendes an
offizielle lügen wollen test und die
herausforderungen der kalifornischen
obdachlosigkeit forbes 2009/10 der müll
die gebrauchten fixer nadeln und die
menschlichen fäkalien die kalifornien
städte verunreinigen haben zu einer
erhöhten zahl von ratten und
infolgedessen zu einer flow plage mit
schnelle ausbreitung tödlicher
krankheiten geführt während in
kalifornien im jahr 2008 typhus nur 13
mal auftrag schnellte diese zahl im jahr
2018 auf 167 fälle hepatitis a
tuberkulose und staphylokokken haben
sich in san francisco und anderen
kalifornische städten aggressiv
ausgebreitet
ja die pest kehrt tatsächlich zurück nur
diesmal ins sonnige kalifornien das
problem der massenhaften obdachlosigkeit
für zu gigantischen sanitären problemen
da oder brücken und in paks massenweise
illegale behausungen ohne jedwede
sanitäre infrastruktur entstehen dazu
gesellen sich unglaublich schnell alle
arten von ungeziefer und eine drogen
epidemie und schon haben wir das rezept
für eine pandemie so und wehe euch
sicher vorstellen könnt sind die
california nicht besonders glücklich
über diese zustände
tatsächlich sind viele von ihnen sehr
sehr wütend auf den staat und bestimmte
gruppen in der gesellschaft elend ist
eben der perfekte nährboden für eine
radikalisierung und polarisierung der
gesellschaft dies ist ein kompliziertes
thema das wahrscheinlich in
eigenständigen beiträgen erläutert
werden müsste aber hier sind nur einige
schlagzeilen damit ihr euch ein bild
machen 21a haftungen während demo in
berkeley bei der hunderte von trump
anhängern und gegendemonstranten
aufeinander stießen er laut times 2017
antifa demonstranten die im jahre 2016
blutige anschläge mit zehn verletzten
verübt haben müssen sich vor gericht
verantworten
das sakrament obi 2009 10
so sieht das kalifornien nämlich in
wirklichkeit aus der durch hippies und
knapp bekleidete girls auf rollschuhen
bekannt gewordene us bundesstaat steuert
in einer sich immer schneller drehende
spirale und auf einen hochgradig
polarisierten abgrund zu die menschen
sehen auf den straßen die flut der
gebrauchten fixer nadeln und kämpfen
damit ihre rechnungen bezahlen zu können
während ein reicher venture capitalist
in seiner riesigen luxus villa nur einen
halben block entfernt wohnt auf den
straßen wimmelt es nicht nur vor
obdachlosen die sich vor kurzem sicher
waren fest zur mittelschicht zu gehören
sondern auch vor anarchisten die
unternehmen hervor sie
und zu gewalttätigen unruhen jager
aufständen anstiften berkeley und san
francisco 1 zentren des amerikanischen
liberalismus werden zu nährboden für
radikalismus
okay was ist reicht es langsam mit den
hiobsbotschaften so langsam denkt ihr
wohl das ist nicht mehr möglich ist ein
noch düstereres bild zu zeichnen nicht
wahr
nun leider oder zum glück reicht unsere
zeit nicht aus um noch auf die vielen
anderen ebenso gravierenden probleme
dieses landes der albträume zu sprechen
zu kommen denn da wären auch noch
schwere umweltprobleme wie die
unerträgliche luftverschmutzung in den
städten außer kontrolle geratene
waldbrände und invasive arten die sich
unkontrolliert ausbreiten und mensch und
tier das leben zur hölle machen
tja und was glaubt ihr was die menschen
in kalifornien tun wenn eure antwort
lautet ein riesiges goldenes denkmal für
arnold schwarzenegger aufstellen dann
habt ihr falsch geraten falls eure
antwort jedoch nichts wie weg hier
lautet dann liegt er goldrichtig im jahr
2018 verließen fast 700.000 kalifornien
ihren bundesstaat ja wirklich die
menschen verlassen kalifornien in
scharen und ziehen in andere
bundesstaaten texas colorado oklahoma
und nevada wo sie niedrigere
lebenshaltungskosten niedriger
steuersätze und ein stärkeres
lohnwachstum vorstellt
herzlichen glückwunsch wir können uns
dazu beglückwünschen in einer zeit zu
leben in der die menschen aus
kalifornien abbauen um sich in oklahoma
ihren lebenstraum erfüllen zu können
aber moment mal werdet ihr jetzt
einsetzen was laberst du da für einen
mist markt hier die einwohnerzahl
kaliforniens nimmt doch beständig zu nun
das stimmt natürlich schließt das was
sich aber zuvor gesagt habe nicht aus
während nämlich 690.000 california
bezogen sind sorgen im gleichen zeitraum
500.000 menschen aus anderen staaten
nach kalifornien
somit ergibt sich aber immer noch ein
inneramerikanische netto migrations
verlust von 190 oder knapp 200.000
menschen für den traum statt und da
vielen menschen im ausland eben immer
noch das bild vom grünen stage dem land
der unbegrenzten möglichkeiten und den
allgegenwärtigen rollstuhl girls im kopf
sitzt kommen aus mexiko nigeria
guatemala den philippinen und osteuropa
so viele einwanderer dass diese flucht
der einheimischen ausgeglichen wird gut
trotz aller probleme ist kalifornien
schon immer noch gott herr mahler
vorzuziehen so und nun seid ihr an der
reihe liebe zuschauer wie wird die
entwicklung weitergehen ist dies nur
eine zwischenphase in der jungen
geschichte dieses staates wird
kalifornien seinen haushalt langfristig
stabilisieren können und den aktuellen
überschuss verantwortungsvoll für
schlechtere zeiten zurücklegen so wie
dies kluge regierungen tun handelt es
sich einfach nur um das ende des
goldenen zeitalters des golden states
oder wird alles noch viel schlimmer wird
aus der asche kaliforniens eine phoenix
auferstehen oder wird diese vom winde
verweht werden wir freuen uns wie immer
auf eure klugen und wohlüberlegten
beiträge im kommentarbereich und wisst
ihr dass wir jede woche frische
informative videos für euch vorbereitet
veröffentlichen wenn ihr keines dieser
aktuellen updates verpassen wollt
abonniert wird es visuell politik und
drückt auch auf die klingel taste und
immer benachrichtigt zu werden und wenn
euch dieses video gefallen gibt uns
einen daumen hoch
macht's gut bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]